there used to be families in every house
on this street you could hear the kids
laughing all the time
what's going on it's cold Grandma's
Grandma's Mikey inside you hungry you
know we don't need anyone to save us
trying to save myself
[Music]
don't know the questions anymore
[Music]
I've got blood on my hands no matter how
hard I try I can't wash away the past
sorry about the smell I'm used to it
for your trouble
[Music]
good
most guys are sponsored they got a hard
time doing work but you you got a
different sort of Melody yeah it ain't
the work just to Letting Go your
grandma's gonna worry you ain't my
father
you find a way to make peace with it
with you
what's up we close
I have to open you up what
God has a plan
we can never go home kill the girl and
the old lady make it messy
I'm Gonna Be Right
home protection hunting
[Applause]
the trash man wasn't always a trash man
except I know how to make these
[Music]
I did
how'd you get this number
same way I got your address